can you buy like cheap chips and cheese
and salsa
and soda
[Music]
I'm gonna tell you guys a story
it's super uh confusing a little bit but
it's pretty awesome you tried to confuse
it don't worry Anthony is not here all
right all right so we start with this
guy right his name's Iowa that's his
actual first name that's already
confused I know aisle worth let me tell
you if it's a Wisconsin story I swear to
God
so this is in 1988 right this guy he was
a Serial assaulter we'll say
um
is it in the essay yes so in 88 he goes
to life in prison he gets sentenced for
life in prison and then one of his
victims actually fought to change the
law back then to where you could get
compensation if you were attacked in
this way
so it's not like child support but
murder support kind of yeah so they no
no like the victims get the money right
yeah now then yeah so this change this
person who was a victim got the law
changed and he had to pay her 50k in
Damages and on top of that he had to pay
800k in legal fees how does he pay that
when he's in jail I he had you paid
overtime
um and so wait it doesn't have life in
prison yeah he has life in prison no how
do you pay over yeah how does he make
money he makes it in jail I don't know
I'm not I'm so confused I could sell his
booty in jail like it said the payments
out probably
how is he getting money maybe it never
comes who knows either way that part
doesn't we don't go back to that
so what happens here so he pays all that
well that's what he gets sentenced to
pay uh the woman does get her 50k and
she donates it all to charity like
that's really cool but then in 2004.
while this guy was in prison in 2004
he's you know he's been in there for
quite some time they let you out every
now and then to do different activities
outside of jail like handball or
something sort of yeah dude yeah camel
all right
2004 he goes and buys a lotto ticket and
he wins 7.2 million oh [__] what the
[__] this is [__] crazy guys nothing
but net this way
he doesn't miss
a lucky son of a [__] he wins 7.2
million he's still in prison for life
basically and uh so they're trying to
tell him that he can't have the money so
he has to hire a lawyer to fight for uh
basically in order to claim this 7.2
million how come he can't have the money
the [__] it's like it's a gray area
because nobody's ever won the lotto from
prison yeah wow wow you should be able
to keep it honestly so what happens is
what the [__] what can you buy like
cheap chips and cheese
and salsa yeah
if all of his victims get all the money
right there so um that'll be good so for
15 years his lawyer's fighting for this
case for him to get this money and not
until now 2023 they finally granted him
access to the 7.2 million is he dead yet
no he's not dead he's like totally good
does he owe 7.2 million legal fees
he doesn't he doesn't even over like and
of course of course like well it doesn't
give us 0.2 right he gets half I
can't buy his way out of prison yeah you
do have to pay a lot of attacks but
basically now that he's gotten granted
that money that original woman she's
trying to pressure him to give it to
charity because she gave her 50k to
charity that he paid her she's trying to
get him to do that she's like pressuring
like uh the the law to like make him do
that oh yeah wow for some reason I'm
rooting for the guy it's just weird
[__] you made your move yeah you made
your moves not thinking he was going
we're at all nice people dude yeah he
wasn't in there for being nice let me
tell you that what about all the other
victims maybe he should pay all them out
oh yeah unless they're dead or something
because he was like one of those kind of
guys that just killed them all I mean
this was in the
end so most I got life
and he must have just [__] up
7.2 million winning the lotto in prison
life in prison imagine being being a
multi-millionaire that's life in prison
what's where is that even worse or is
that better because you can't even use
it that's what it works yeah oh yeah
yeah so what are you gonna do with it
yeah but you I guess you could buy Ramen
for the jail dude and everyone loves you
because you're just on the house every
day Ramen that's what I'm saying like
he'll never he'll never get
like you can buy like tickets and stuff
for things in jail right with money with
real money you can't buy your way out of
prison yeah but he could buy his way up
from not getting like touched by guys in
there yeah that's true
hey I know you want to [__] me dude but
listen here it's an actual ticket to
give you 10 000 honestly a family don't
touch me yeah
don't touch that no touch ticket but
what about
um that's him yeah can he pay for like
lawyers and [__] like that with it to
try to get them out yeah yeah but dude
well I don't know
he was this guy he he did those crimes
to a lot of people like oh [__] he's not
coming out serial assaulter
that's that's him in the 80s when he was
uh dude it looks like Paul Rudd he's got
the Furby guys you know
it's got those pervy eyes why am I
rooting for him for some reason you want
to help me put these boxes inside
yeah let's figure out let's figure out
why we're rooting for him are you guys
rooting for him no
um maybe I'm just weird well because the
lottery doesn't like he just got lucky
that's it it doesn't mean you know he
deserved it I think it means he's a good
person
I think if you win the lottery it means
you're a good or you've done so much
good in your life yeah you're finally
lucky yeah yeah good Karma's
busy you know what he's already been
buying stuff what's he been buying oh
[__] he he has like a property portfolio
now he has an art collection he bought a
Picasso
what is he gonna do like he's just gonna
be [__] in prison dude thinks he's
always wanted it might be like lawyers
that are doing it for him no Well I this
is what can I tell you what I think I
think he's got the money I think he
transfer the money to his family and his
family's doing the buying for him he has
a family he's not a family he's probably
got like someone who cares about his mom
over there smoke a cigarette God what do
you want to do with an extra male it's
like I don't know if I can give it to
Cherry or some [__] [__] that
I'm gonna buy some guns how about that
what can do it Mike posso [__] might
as well too dark my guy get out of there
oh oh oh oh oh okay well break let's
okay right you got 7.2 you spend one
million on some guy crashing into the
[__] building for me that's prison
break you had a good idea
your wording was terrible help me help
me out I would have just said I would
just hire some guy to come in there and
just break it but when can he say 9 11.
when is he gonna fit in 911
the fact that they came out of your
mouth was like
I could have been said without what you
needed to do is you needed to use a
reference that no one gave a [__] about
like Kamikaze but saying something like
suicide bomber or 911 just it's too
close to home when white people care
about it that's when it's dangerous
give it another go think about Asian
deaths that's what people don't care
about okay he could have hired uh
Asian lady driver
and she's gonna crash anyways dad crash
into the prison
[Applause]
I would have went with a Chinese balloon
but Asian driver's license Chinese
weather balloon
it's a writer's room we're working in
our Chinese truck driver I like where
you're going with it yeah
the white women are like oh thank God
it's 9 11. tears oh thank God
so I guess he's like technically he's
released on license which sounds like
the the British equivalent to like out
always
yeah oh this changes everything wait
he's out now now I'm not rooting for him
anymore yeah yeah it's like even though
he has life because that has a too good
no no I'm not written for him he's a
brick he's not actually [__] this guy
you know when you're when you're
disturbing your sentence but you're
you're you've been in there so long you
start serving it outside of the jail how
is that even life in prison if you're
not in prison that's not life in prison
that's like life on houses you know how
the Brits are these guys on Andrew take
stuff dude it's like you're on you're on
parole but it's super strict or house
arrest kind of deal nah take the
millions away [__] this guy dude
I think he is Pablo Escobar yeah it says
that he lives in a like a a property on
a Countryside with his long-term partner
it's all super nice the [__] now he
could actually use his millions I want
his life I want to be creative in jail
yeah that's what I wanted yeah yeah I
want her to build like [__] bird
houses and [__] like that make those
like awkward ballots I wanted him to
build his own [__] in and out outside
of his cell window that'd be so hard
that would be so hard that's like Richie
Rich type [__] though yeah I would buy
one of those like Mexican [__] uh
parrots and just looking to talk to me
and [__] like that with the seven
million dollars those [__] parents
are smart dude they have a whole
conversation with you yeah and then they
could like tell them to go get you
something to go get it bring you
cigarettes weed and [__] yeah anything
you want dude yeah a bunch bunch of
stuff it's so red
okay the french fries
don't talk to me like that yeah he's not
actually in jail but he's like on a
strict uh thing where he can't do nah he
needs to go back to jail spend his time
in there yeah I was gonna let this guy
out there he [__] tortured so many
women and he gets to be out that's weird
that's what she's saying that's why
she's campaigning that he should have to
like pay reparations man the UK got some
weird laws dude that's backwards he
probably paid someone out so he can uh
live his at his house dude would you
guys be be down to be a millionaire
but you have to be vegetarian for the
rest of your life oh [__] no I'm broke
I mean me me too give me that protein
dog give me that meat now that I can
finally afford A5 wagyu yeah
foreign
[Music]